everybody from Boston looks like Mike
from Breaking Bad ghost car sees ghosts
cam ghosts cows I mean what killing cows
left and right never seen one ghost cow
Moo is one letter from Moo cows cows hey
new material how you doing Pete pretty
good let me ask you a question
hmm do you read books do you really want
to know or you just want to run a bit by
me I'm asking you do you read books yeah
I'd like books from time to time box you
read them but when you run fast
that means you booked that guy got
caught by the cops
what happened he didn't book it fast
enough what did he do he stole a book
stole a book Danny bought now they're
going to take him to the station and
book him he's got a trial next Thursday
the judge is gonna throw the book at him
you like that is there anything yeah
that funny I think that's funny he
booked it he stole a book on skate
there's more what's with all the food
courts what is this where renegade foods
go on trial well that's the quartet
you're gonna fry for what you did
chicken you're gonna hang salami it's
not anything I don't write I need a
third one um maybe like a turkey is
getting a lethal injection with like a
turkey baster why would they have turkey
in a food court it's not Thanksgiving
why would there be salami is hanging up
it's not Little Italy you're right it's
not that good of a bit
oh it's there's something there what
else do I have here
straight there's too many types of
straight too many streets Avenue Road
Expressway some kinds of streets are
called drives I know I'm on a drive I'm
driving on it you're a street you're a
street Boulevard where do you have your
PhD
oh I'm James Boulevard Esquire you're a
straight place you aren't a place you'll
lead
a place government you're a street
highway
who the hell does this guy think he is
calling himself a highway get off your
high horse highway what made you call
yourself that what are you high way rain
how can you call yourself a lane when
there's more than one lane it should be
called Elaine's Elaine's lanes George
Kramer don't see that's that funny is
that good than anything I don't I don't
know me and I it's okay I just think you
can do better
hey I'm dropping it thanks for the input
Pete have a good set thanks man
oh you forgot your uh your set list
thank you
types of streams Boulevard what do you
got your PhD you're a straight